- [Narrator] In this video,
we're going to talk about
density in the context of area.
And the simplest way of
thinking about it is density
is going to be some
quantity per unit area.
So for example, let's say
that I have a football
field right over here
and I have another identical
football field right over here.
Now they have the same area,
but if I have let's say five
people on this football field
actually six people on
this football field.
And I only have three people
on this football field
the density of people
per average unit area
or the density of people I
should say per football field
is going to be higher
in this left example.
So it's always going to
be quantity per area.
Now, with that out of the
way, let's do a worked example
that helps us understand this
idea a little bit better.
So here we're told the town of Tigersville
has a population density of
13 cats per square kilometer.
So they're giving us the density
let me write that 13 cats.
So the quantity is quantity
and cats per square kilometer.
That's the density right over there.
The town is shaped like a
perfect isosceles trapezoid.
So it looks something
like this say perfect isosceles trapezoid.
It's gonna look something like that,
with two parallel boundaries,
12 kilometers apart.
So this distance right
over here is 12 kilometers
one measuring eight kilometers.
So this side over here is eight kilometers
the other is 16 that's
a longer one over there.
How many cats are in Tigersville?
So they give us the density
here and they give us,
I think enough information
to figure out the area.
And they want us to figure
out how many cats we have.
So what is the quantity?
So pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
Well, just as we said the density
is equal to quantity divided by area.
If we multiply both sides
of this equation by area
you get area times density is
going to be equal to quantity.
And we know the density.
It's 13 cats per square
kilometer, and we can figure out
the area and then just multiply the two.
So what's the area of
this right over here?
Well, the area of a
trapezoid is going to be,
write here area is going
to be 12 kilometers.
The height of the trapezoid
times the average of
the two parallel sides
I guess you could say.
So the average of those it's
going to be eight kilometers
plus 16 kilometers over two.
So this is going to be
equal to 12 kilometers
times eight plus 16 is
24 divided by two is 12.
So times 12 kilometers.
So this gives us 144 square kilometers.
Now we know we have 13
cats per square kilometer.
So let me do this year in another color.
So if I multiply 13 cats
per kilometer squared
and I multiply that times
this business right over here,
times 144 square kilometers.
And you might also notice
that the units cancel out
the same way that variables might.
So that cancels out with that.
You're going to get 13 times 144.
And the units that you're
left with is just cats.
So 144 times 13, three times four is 12
that gives us to 13,
three times a hundred,
300 plus another hundred is 400.
Now I'm just gonna multiply
144 essentially by 10
which is going to be 1440.
And so if I add up all of that together
I'm gonna jump down to here.
I get 1872.
So this is 1872 cats in
total and we are done.